today all of these people that are
coming up with these trans able you know
is what I I identify as blind I identify
as this Dwyane Wade said well you know I
can't uh identify myself as somebody
that can live in a state of Florida as
two extreme of policies with what the
governor is doing there you know with a
trans kid I have decided to take my kids
to a different place no problem yeah you
know today he may seem like a noble
parent and it may look like what a sweet
father what a great mother you guys are
you know obviously the biological mother
didn't support it but you know Dwayne
Wade more power to you but in 10 years
when that kid is 25 years old on 20
years when that kid is 35 years old that
kid is going to say why'd you let me do
that as a 13 14. I had no clue what I
was doing why'd you let me make a
decision like that why don't you wait
till I was an adult why did you do that
Dad then we are all gonna realize
whether that decision that was made in
2023 or 2022 it was a bad decision and
unfortunately Megan this is the problem
unfortunately
some of these shitty ideas these guys
are coming up with that are seeming like
they're such noble people it's going to
take 10 to 20 years to realize they were
horrible ideas and a lot of people
especially helpless people like kids are
going to suffer the consequences so as
loud as many of us are going to be as
much as we're going to go out there and
present Common Sense unfortunately some
of these bad ideas are creating momentum
and it's hurting the people that are
helpless
um
you we talked about of course Dwayne
Reed Wade and Gabrielle Union and his
wife they're mad at Ron DeSantis they're
mad about the allegedly don't say gay
bill it's not it's a misnomer
um you can say gay all day long you can
say it all day like I said in school you
can actually have discussions about it
it's just not going to be in your
curriculum
um so they're leaving Florida
foreign